close up our brains are a thick tangle
of nerve cells connected to each other
at sign apses and surrounded by support
cells and blood vessels working out
exactly what connects to what and how
those connections enable us to see to
store memories and to make decisions is
a huge challenge not least because a
human brain contains around 100 billion
nerve cells making several trillion
connections so scientists started with a
much simpler animal a tiny dirt dwelling
worm with only 302 cells in its entire
nervous system even so it took over a
decade to complete these wiring diagrams
the worm mappers used a technique called
serial electron microscopy now two teams
have reinvented the technique and
applied it to small bits of a much more
complex brain at the Max Planck
Institute for medical research in
Germany they focused on the mouse retina
even a tiny bit of retina the size of a
grain of salt contains such a dense
tangle of neurons that capture every
twist and turn you need to take tens of
thousands of pictures so the team built
a souped-up microscope an automated
machine to cut the sample into extremely
thin slices and image it with beams of
electrons by Reece tacking these digital
images they were able to reconstruct the
speck of retina in all its detail the
job required one terabyte of data and
immense computing power researchers at
Harvard used a similar technique to
slice up and reassemble a small section
of mouse visual cortex the part of the
brain where information from the retina
is processed but what makes these
studies special is that before slicing
and mapping the teams watched the brain
in action and recorded the behavior of
cells in their sample
the German team showed their mouse a
moving light beam indicated here by a
white arrow and watched to see which
cells fired
they assigned each cell a color
according to its response pink for
rightwards motion red for left words and
so on then they identified the same
neurons in the 3d reconstruction and
starting with the cell body they
manually traced the cells multiple
projections and connections
it's a painstaking process and it took
the team hours to trace just a few cells
as well as being a huge technical feat
examining the brain this level of detail
teaches us how it processes information
here are the cells mapped by the Harvard
team including their connections with
other cells shown in pink and pale blue
the researchers hope to scale up from a
handful of cells to hundreds and then
thousands but that's still a long way
from mapping every nerve cell and every
synapse in a mammalian brain what's more
it's only a snapshot the connections in
our brain constantly change as we learn
and lay down memories and at the micro
level no two brains are the same so
scientists are also mapping the brain on
the macro scale and trying to work out
how it changes through development and
how it varies from person to person this
is the goal of the human connectome
project which uses data from MRI studies
to map long distance connections made by
bundles of nerve fibers these are the
super highways linking different brain
areas collectively these projects are
known as connect omics and they're
sometimes compared in scale and ambition
to the human genome project another tool
in the connectome Xbox is Brainbow by
engineering neurons to emit different
shades of fluorescent light scientists
at Harvard produced these beautiful
Technicolor images the colors help
scientists distinguish and follow
individual neurons together all these
projects may one day reveal how a
tangled mess of billions of cells
enables us to see to dream and to study
the brain as scientists and how to
repair it when it goes wrong
you